before dawn they were laying out the red
carpet to the steps of air force one
the band was rehearsing the
accompaniment for the departure of a
president
by daylight the crowd of supporters and
staff had arrived
it had the feel of one last rally just
smaller
and sadder usually a president would be
with his successor
at this moment ladies and gentlemen
please welcome
the president and first lady but donald
trump wasn't going to be a bit part
in someone else's show
the military send-off was what he wanted
the sadness clear
on the faces of the trump family as he
and the first lady
said goodbye being your first lady
was my greatest honor thank you for your
love
and your support you will be in my
thoughts and prayers
god bless you all it is my greatest
honor
and privilege to have been your
president i will
always fight for you i will be watching
i will be listening goodbye we love you
we will be back in some form
have a good life we will see you soon
thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
[Music]
like so much about donald trump's
presidency the end was
unlike anything this country has ever
seen there was a sense that he was
lingering on the stage unwilling to
finally
say goodbye and a sense also that he is
far from done
with the political world in america this
was a crowd far from ready to let him go
i've been grieving um but i
have a lot of hope as well he's given so
much
i'm not sure what he will do in the
future i'm just very thankful that we
had him for four years
he seemed to suggest he might be back in
future would you like to see him back in
politics
from your mouth to god's ear they waved
goodbye as america began its own
reckoning with the presidency of donald
trump
ever the showman the soundtrack for his
departure was
no accident
[Music]
he landed in florida still technically
president for a few moments more
the first lady dressed seemingly ready
for a new life
on the route home the sort of reception
he's grown to love
god
[Applause]
the loyal following which has driven him
on for four years
and may yet convince him that staying
out of the limelight just isn't an
option
we almost certainly haven't heard the
last of donald trump
greg milam sky news